[MUSIC PLAYING]
GERARDO CAPIEL:
I'm Gerardo Capiel,
and I lead product management
for Consumer Payments
here at Google.
And with me is my partner
in crime, Varouj Chitilian.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
All right, who's
excited to hear about
Google Pay today?
GERARDO CAPIEL: Woo.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
GERARDO CAPIEL: Great,
so earlier this year we
unified all the
ways that you can
pay with Google into a single
brand called Google Pay.
With Google Pay,
you can play online
and at millions of places
all around the world
with the payment
information that you
saved in your Google account.
Today, we're going to be talking
about the great ways in which
we're making it easier,
faster, and more
rewarding for your customers to
check out online and in stores.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: We want to
make payments easy for everyone
everywhere.
See, Google Pay is
not just an app.
Google Pay makes payments a
foundational and integral part
of a Google user's account.
So for Google users logged
into any Google service,
they can experience
amazing payment experiences
that Google Pay provides.
The other advantage to tying
everything to one account
is that payment methods
and transactions can all be
managed in a central location.
Now we all know that mobile
is the fastest growing
e-commerce surface,
but your customers
are transacting on all surfaces.
So we want to make
sure with Google Pay
that Google users can pay as
easily in stores with a tap
as they can online at
your sites and apps,
as well as on Google, on
Chrome, on YouTube, Google Play,
and even Google Assistant.
GERARDO CAPIEL: Thanks, Varouj.
So what's in it for
all you developers
out here in the crowd?
Well, currently
there are hundreds
of millions of payment methods
saved to Google accounts
when users transact
on Play or when they
save their cards in Chrome.
We know from operating Google
Play, one of the world's
largest e-commerce marketplaces,
that these users that
have saved payment
methods to their account
are much more likely to
complete a transaction than when
they have it.
And we call these users
ready-to-pay users.
Via our APIs, we're going to
enable these ready-to-pay users
to also check out quickly
and easily in your own apps
and websites, which
means that you're
going to see increased
conversion rates, faster
monetization.
And you'll be able to
provide your customers
with the same easy quick
checkout experience
that we provide on Play.
Now speaking of
payment methods, let
me turn to the Google Pay app.
So in an upcoming update
of the Google Pay app,
we're going to allow you
to manage all the payment
methods in your Google account,
not just the payment methods
that you use to pay in-store.
And even better, we're
going to provide you
with a holistic view of
all your transactions,
whether they be on
Google Apps and services,
such as Play and
YouTube, whether they
be with third-party merchants,
such as Walgreens and Uber,
or whether they're
transactions you've
made to friends and families
via our peer-to-peer service.
And of course, the app
is available on Android.
But I'm really excited
to tell you all
that we're bringing this
capability to iOS and the web.
Woo!
So let's dig a little deeper
into the Google Pay app.
So if you've opened the
app, you come to a Home tab.
Hopefully many of
you have seen this.
And this tab is
personalized for you
based on the credit and debit
cards in your Google account,
based on the loyalty
programs that you
have saved to Google
Pay, based on the offers
that you have saved
to Google Pay,
and even based on the
stores that are nearby you.
You can see examples of
the many types of cards
that you might find in the home
feed of the Google Pay app.
Now what's really exciting is
that some of these feed cards
are actionable.
So for example, this
card that you see here
allows you to sign up
for Balance Rewards.
Or, if you already
belong, it allows
you to link your Balance Rewards
account to your Google account.
And this card is geo-aware.
And so what that means
is it only shows up
when you're at Walgreens.
So that's what makes the Home
tab so personalized and great.
So merchants out there and
providers of loyalty programs
and offers programs that
wish to take advantage
of these features
should join the ranks
of the hundreds of partners that
have implemented the Google Pay
APIs for loyalty.
And to learn more, I encourage
you to go to g.co/pay/business.
Now we're also working
with ticketing providers
so that our users can easily
and quickly save event tickets
and boarding passes to
their Google account,
and then be able to access them
right in the Google Pay app.
I'm excited to announce
some of our early access
partners, some of which I
see out here in the crowd,
such as Singapore Airlines,
Southwest, Eventbrite,
and Fortress GB, who
provides ticketing
infrastructure to major soccer
leagues in the UK and beyond.
So to talk more about transit,
I'm going to turn it to Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Yeah,
so loyalty and payments
covers most of what's
in your wallet.
But transit is a massive use
case for our Google users.
Now Google Pay already
supports transit, and has
for a while at transit agencies
that accept contactless debit
or credit cards.
So we see transactions in
London, Chicago, Kiev, Sydney,
Portland, and coming
soon in Vancouver.
But if we only support
contactless debit or credit
cards for transit, we'll
be leaving a large portion
of our Google users that use
traditional transit tickets
and passes under-served.
And so we've been partnering
with transit technology
providers, like NXP and
ITSO, to natively support
these traditional tickets and
passes within the Google Pay
app.
So you may have heard recently
that we launched in Las Vegas
as well as in Portland.
And today we'd like to
announce that coming soon we'll
have support in West
Midlands in the UK.
So very, very exciting.
Now we're working really
hard on Google Pay,
and Google Pay is already
available to hundreds
of millions of
users in 18 markets.
And I'm really proud to say that
just recently Google Pay passed
100 million downloads in the
Google Play Store-- very--
GERARDO CAPIEL: Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: But
we're not stopping there.
Very soon, we will
be launching many
of the core features and the
Google Play app globally.
That means that
billions of Google users
worldwide will be
able to leverage
the amazing payment experiences
that Google Pay provides,
so we're very, very
excited about this.
GERARDO CAPIEL: Great.
It is super exciting.
And users in the UK and
the US have one more thing
to be excited about--
we are bringing
peer-to-peer payment right
into the Google Pay app.
That means that you'll be
able to send and request money
directly from the
app in the Send tab.
But even more
exciting than that is
that you're going to
be able to easily split
that purchase for tickets to
the soccer game or the drinks
at the pub easily right
from the Google Pay app.
So if you pull up the
transaction details
after paying for drinks at
the pub, right from there
you'll be able to split the
expense with your friends.
Super exciting.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Awesome.
And guess what?
For many of these
payment experiences,
you don't even need to have
the Google Pay app installed.
For example, our P2P
experience is already
embedded in Gmail, Android
Contacts, Google Assistant,
Apple iMessage, and
Android Messages.
Last year, we announced
the ability for you,
through your mobile banking,
to provision a debit or credit
card into Google Pay to be able
to use it in stores and online.
This year, we take it a step
further with our banking
partners.
You can now sign up for
a new credit or debit
card in the mobile banking app,
have that provision to Google
Pay, and start using it even
before the credit or debit
card arrives in the mail.
That awesome?
GERARDO CAPIEL:
That's pretty cool.
That is pretty cool.
And so now that we've taken
you through this whirlwind tour
of everything that's been
happening since we were last
up here, which
has been dizzying,
and the things that are making
it easier, simpler, and more
rewarding for our users to
pay online and in stores,
let's talk about the specific
ways in which you all here can
create great experiences
for your customers online
and in stores.
So let's start with online.
What I really like about
online is its scale.
There are millions and millions
of merchants all around
the world where you
can buy things online.
And we want to make every
single one of those checkout
experiences great.
So that means that we
need solutions that scale.
And ideally they're
solutions where
you don't have to do anything,
or just do very little.
Chrome AutoFill is one
of those experiences.
Chrome AutoFill
removes the hassle
from users of having to type
in credit card numbers, type
in shipping addresses
and billing address.
It makes it super simple.
So hopefully your site
already works perfectly
with Chrome AutoFill.
But we know that there's a
number out there that don't.
So we want to make sure
that your users are
able to take advantage of
AutoFill as best as possible.
And we've published a set of
guidelines and best practices
that will enable you to test
and optimize your checkout
forms for Chrome AutoFill.
To learn more, go to
g.co/pay/autofill.
Or, when you exit out o
here, visit our sandbox right
across the way and
speak with our engineers
about how you can optimize
your checkout flow.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: So if
we focused exclusively
on AutoFill, we'd be doing
Google users a disservice.
The North Star here is really
to skip the checkout form
altogether.
And that's where the Google
Pay APIs for checkout come in.
Now we announced the online
payment APIs last year.
But since then, we've made
three major enhancements
that I'd like to
talk to you about.
Number 1, we're announcing
JavaScript bindings
for the Google Pay
API for checkout.
That means you can provide your
customers with great payment
experiences that Google Pay
provides across all browsers.
Number 2, in our APIs we
use a very consistent JSON
representation of the
request and response object.
What this means is that if
you implement the Google Pay
APIs for checkout, for example,
for web, for JavaScript,
you can easily port
that, including
the payment
processing to your app
and also to Google Assistant.
I actually want to show you a
quick demo here-- not a demo
but screens here of what we've
done with Fandango that's
coming soon where
you can actually
get a very easy checkout
experience from Google
Search when you use Google
Pay APIs for checkout.
So a user searches for
tickets on Google.com,
then they go to
that Fandango site
where they can easily
select and purchase tickets
using Google Pay.
So very exciting.
And the last thing,
that last enhancement
that I'd like to talk
about, is that we've
enhanced our ready-to-pay API.
With this API, you can tell
whether a user on your site,
a customer on your site,
has payment method that you
can actually accept.
And what this allows
you to do is now
that I know that this
is a ready-to-pay user,
you can really streamline
the checkout experience
and really drive
increased conversions.
GERARDO CAPIEL: Right,
that's pretty cool.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Let's
see this stuff in action.
GERARDO CAPIEL: But
it's even cooler
when you see it in action.
Let's turn to the
computer, please.
Great.
So last year when
we were up here,
we showed you the great
checkout experience
that we created on
the web, but it was
limited to Chrome on Android.
I'm really excited that
we've now extended this
to many other browsers,
such as Safari,
both on desktop
and iOS, Firefox,
and a number of browsers, and
Edge and Internet Explorer
are coming soon.
And you'll be able to play
with this yourselves right
after this slide.
So I'm on our demo site, time
to get some new Google gear.
So I like this shell right here.
So I go to the
Product Details page
and I see that there is a
Buy with Google Pay button.
And this is good because, you
may not know this, but over 60%
of online purchases are
really just for one item.
So why put users through
a multi-step checkout flow
where they have to add to a
card and all these other steps.
Let's just let them buy what
they want right directly
from Product Details.
So when I click there,
because I was already
logged into my Google
account since I was maybe
checking my Gmail
or using YouTube,
whatever other Google service,
I'm automatically logged in.
I see the payment
methods that I've
saved to my Google account
and other information that's
in my Google account, such
as my shipping address.
And then I just hit
Continue, and voila--
I am done.
It's that simple.
OK, so that's cool.
But on Chrome, we're doing
something even more cool
in the near future.
So on Chrome, we are creating
a near native experience
that is fast and seamless and
tightly integrated into Chrome,
as you can see right here.
When I move my window
around, things stay in place.
And this is really great.
Let's turn it back to
the slides, please.
So if you want to check this
out yourselves on your iPhone
or on your desktop, go
to g.co/pay/webdemo.
So fewer distractions, faster
checkout, simpler checkout
means greater conversion.
And we're pretty
confident that you're
going to see these
types of results
when you implement
the Google Pay API.
Since we announced Google Pay,
the response from merchants
has been overwhelming
all around the world.
We've added merchants such
as Uber and DoorDash, ASOS,
Deliveroo, and-- soon coming--
Starbucks.
And our partners are
seeing great results.
StubHub, for example, since
they've implemented the newest
version of our API, has seen
a 7x increase in transactions
through Google Pay.
And Airbnb saw an 11x
increase in transactions
through Google Pay.
And it's also interesting
that Hotel Tonight--
interesting and great-- has
found that users that use
Google Pay to complete a booking
are 65% more likely to complete
the transaction than
those who don't.
So really, really great results.
Super exciting.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
Varouj, tell us more.
Yeah, so if you guys take
one thing away from I/O
on the payment side,
you should definitely
figure out how you're going
to implement these Google Pay
APIs for a checkout
on your surfaces
to give your customers
incredible payment experiences.
And we have two additional
sessions that you can go to.
The first is tomorrow-- what's
new for online checkout.
And that's on stage 6.
And the second is
by our UX team,
it's called Google Pay best
practices for great payment
experiences.
And that's on stage
7 on Thursday.
So please go and
check those out.
GERARDO CAPIEL: Great.
So let's talk next
about something
that users love more
than saving time--
saving money.
Who doesn't love to save money?
So Google Pay is more
than just a way to pay.
We've invested heavily
in making Google
Pay a platform by which
you can engage your users
through loyalty and offers.
In previous years,
we've been up here
and we've talked about our
Smart Tap protocol, which
is based on NFC and
allows users when they're
in store to just tap once
and convey their loyalty
credentials and offers along
with payment information.
It's a great experience.
And merchants all
around the world
have been implementing
Smart Tap in creating
great value-added check out
experiences for their users.
So I'm excited to announce
today that Russia's Verbank is
the latest partner that
is going to be rolling out
Smart Tap across thousands
of merchants in Russia.
And this is super exciting.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Varouj?
Yeah, but we're not
just stopping at loyalty
and offers when it
comes to Smart Tap.
We're working with
tickets as well.
And in fact, we have an
incredible demo today
that we've done
with our partners
at Ticketmaster that brings
together all the APIs and Smart
Tap into one demo.
So let's go to the phone.
So you'll have to use
your imagination here.
Let's all pretend
we're in Orlando, so
excuse the humidity.
And I'm a massive soccer
fan, and my favorite team
is the Chicago Fire of the MLS.
So Chicago Fire is
visiting Orlando City SC.
And I really want to check
out this game with Gerardo.
So I'm going to open
the Ticketmaster app.
Now since they're my favorite
team, it'll be in Favorites.
So now I select the game, I
select the ticket, do Buy Now.
And here we see the Buy
with Google Pay button.
So I'll give that a click,
and I'll complete checkout.
Boom-- I've purchased tickets.
[APPLAUSE]
GERARDO CAPIEL: Gets
better, though, gets better.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: What's that?
GERARDO CAPIEL: I
said it gets better.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
Oh, it gets better.
Yeah.
So now I can view these tickets.
And here we see the
Save to Phone buttons
that Gerardo mentioned.
So I can save this
ticket to Google Pay.
So now let's open
the Google Pay app.
When I go to the
cards, I now notice
that I have my tickets here for
Orlando SC versus Chicago Fire.
And I'm all ready
to go to this game.
So I'm super excited.
GERARDO CAPIEL:
Get your gear on.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: But
here's the kicker--
no pun intended--
I can actually go to the
gate to get into the game.
And I don't need to fiddle
around with paper tickets
and I don't need
to scan QR codes.
All I need to do--
GERARDO CAPIEL: Let's turn
it to the [INAUDIBLE]..
Thank you.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
Is tap, and I've
gained entry into the stadium.
[APPLAUSE]
And I go along the way.
So these are the incredible
user journeys that we can create
together with these APIs.
Back to the slides?
GERARDO CAPIEL:
OK, that was great.
Now that we've overloaded
you with information
about all the great things that
you can do with Google Pay,
what are next steps?
So the first one is super
easy because it just
takes a few steps.
You exit out this door and
you head over to our sandbox.
And there you can meet with
the engineers that have
built all these amazing things.
And you can get your questions
answered, you can get demos.
And some of the demos even
get you cookies-- and I'm not
talking about browser cookies,
like real tasty good cookies.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Oh, man,
I'm getting hungry up here.
GERARDO CAPIEL: Yeah.
And as we've mentioned
throughout the presentation,
there are several deep
dives the rest of this week
into the different things
that we talked about today.
First of all, I'd
encourage you to go check
out tomorrow night at
6:30 on this stage the
what's new for online
checkout session, which
is going to be run by one of
our PMs and one of the engineers
that have built all
these amazing things.
Then on Thursday,
our payments UX
team is going to be doing
a session on best practices
for creating great
checkout flows.
And they're going to touch
upon many of the things
that we talked about
today, but really go
a lot deeper and beyond.
And then finally on
Thursday afternoon,
right near here on
stage 5, you can
learn about how you can add
transactional capabilities
to your actions.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
So if you can't
make the sessions
or the sandbox,
or if you're watching
on Livestream
and you want to
learn more, these
are some of the
resources you can go to.
g.co/pay/autofill will give
you best practices on how
to optimize your
site for Autofill.
G.co/pay/business will give
you an overview of everything
we've discussed today.
And if you're a developer and
you just want to jump right
into the API documentation,
please go to g.co/pay/dvelopers
to get to the API
documentations directly.
It's going backwards.
So I want to say thank
you to all the developers
and the developer
community in the room.
Really, these
payment experiences
are a partnership between us.
We can't provide these
peer payment experiences
to your customers without you.
And so thank you very much for
coming today, and thank you
for working with
us in developing
these incredible experiences
together with Google Pay.
Thank you.
GERARDO CAPIEL:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]